jason go watch the stuff don't bring it
up yeah nobody [ __ ] with my sh
hey folks my name is jason sedakis and
these are my essentials
[Music]
look i'm going to be transparent with
you i'm shooting a tv show here ted
lasso the second season of that
in london so i don't have my most
essential essentials i have my
bare minimum essentials but these are
the things i
you know i roll with you know and they
all go in this number one essential
this
that's my backpack this was a birthday
gift for my 40th birthday
about five years ago from shinola it is
a
beautiful beautiful like deep green
when i worked at saturday night live i
tried the you know the side saddle
i tried like a jack spade bag like a
messenger bag and i just
found myself going back to the backpack
time and time and time again
it's been beaten up and broken in and
worn in and you know shinola makes good
shinola
the laptop sleeve which there is one in
here
not important to me because i use this
uh mont blanc sleeve within a sleeve so
it you know
it doesn't matter where i put it but
that's where i keep my
my laptop
i would say the laptop is the most
essential because yeah this is what i
you know write
rewrite send notes for everything with
the show
i mean the whole first season because
post-production was done during covet
time i mean i
basically edited on this thing too you
know through zoom you know speaking with
our editors so for anybody at home
you can make a tv show with just one of
these
especially when someone that makes these
pays for it it makes it a lot easier
and it also has you know dozens and
dozens of
dozens of thousands you know probably
like 50 000
personal photos of all my years through
snl family photos
if i lost that i would be
can i say
the next essential that's a red pen
right there your pilot g2 this is
basically what i do
all the notes on any hard copy of a
script or anything i start with a box of
these and i
lose them throughout the season another
red pen up in there
another red pen sharpies
just in case the delete key on the you
know the laptop is
is very functional but a lot of times i
work with hard copies just because it's
easier to jot down notes it's just the
way i got used to doing it at saturday
night live from you know
people like tina fey and jim downey and
you know
mike shurer and seth meyers like why
would i change now so
yeah the pilot g2
[Music]
if you do this it makes it look like
it's rubber all right
i've got two decks of cards in there red
and blue
tally hoes i like magic i like card
tricks i get a lot of idle time
in the world these days you know and i
was like i don't just want to stare at
my phone
and get mad all the time i want to do
something else with my hands and
messing with a deck of cards was it's
almost like a professional like fidget
spinner to just sit there and like
shuffle cards
and i just like i've just kind of gotten
used to like screwing with them
every now and then if i've had enough
beers i'll do like card tricks for
friends but for the most part they're in
there just to pass time
in cars or on set or doing tarot card
readings if you
you know know the symbolism i i don't
but you know
i think aces are good
[Music]
again you know operating out of a
backpack
this is kiehl's blue herbal spot
treatment that's for
pimples keel's like a company i feel
that as a guy
from the midwest who doesn't pay too
much attention to the
way he um looks it feels like i'm not
too far off this feels like
being a grown up and being responsible
and like this
and the face scrub that's about that's
about that's about what i do
and that's that's that
[Music]
well here we go this is important you
might know what this is it's my
eyeglasses
these are my glasses essential for a
number of things
most importantly seeing also for looking
smarter than i really am
i use these i am nearsighted which means
i can't see far away
and this is a brand called tart optical
i have a lot of different
styles of this exact same frame like a
lot of different flavors i would say
like brown and clear and
you know mocha or whatever the heck
these have done these have done the
trick
and oh oh this is being filmed
oh i'll always wear glasses every time
i think about doing lasik i just uh buy
new
like frames and and then that desire to
have someone shoot lasers into my eye is
is removed headphones
i got you know air pods i got you know
airpod pros in here somewhere i think
too
wait a minute do i have the airpod pros
look at this i mean
i've got them like airpod pros regular
air pods
and then the airpods max or i forget
what they call these
these are what i use when mixing the
show because you know you want to be
able to hear everything
they're great they fit great they look
cool phone calls i just go with the
airpods
and then the airpod pros are great but
like i've got weird little ear holes
when the thing goes in there i'm just
not built for them as well like they
fall out
i love headphones i grew up traveling on
a team bus playing basketball in high
school in college
in the 90s so i'm used to carrying big
headphones when big headphones came into
play
and a disc man so now you know with
bluetooth and everything no wires
i'm happy to live in the future here but
i'm always on the search for them i love
what they do at beats i love mastering
dynamic
banging loves all of a sudden if there's
a groovy pair of headphones out there i
usually
you know try to check them out and these
are great because they just slide right
into the
right right into the thing and also uh
the kind folks at apple
uh gave them to me for free
this is just a notepad it's a website i
really like cool material there's a
notepad that i
fill up with with various ideas it says
brilliant ideas i had while stoned
um and that's not always the case we are
all capable of having brilliant ideas
when we're sober
but this is where the stone ones go if
you're looking for
you know mother's day it's right around
the corner no you know
i do skew more analog hence the red pen
i'd carry around a notebook for my
chicago days of doing a sketch and
improv like when you would have a good
idea you jot it down i still keep my
notebooks
near and dear to me
this isn't my passport but this is my
global entry card
that's an essential i'm covering it up
so that you
you little stinkers out there can't
steal my global identity
not to be able to do much with it but
yeah oh
it expires no i'm sorry it is expired it
expired last september
this son of a gun right here this is it
this is a leather man
squirt it's like a little tiny leather
man like a swiss army knife
you're not that big son of a gun that
your dad's friend wore
on his belt all the time no it's like a
little guy
this thing is open wine bottles and beer
bottles
i mean i've used this puppy to like trim
my mustache
i mean look at that and i use that for
nose hairs
this is my second one the first one
again i got as a gift and i traveled
with it
a year two years and then i was heading
home and
security back in kansas city stopped me
and took it out i was like you can't
have that i'm like
i've been everywhere with this i've
literally been here with this come and
gone
and then they they took it i repurchased
another one
on my own so it'll go at any point
maybe it's contraband maybe it's illegal
i don't know you know i guess security
isn't
a form of art that i was unaware of so
yeah
leatherman squirt
all right well folks those are my
essentials that travel with me
in my backpack now you know a little bit
more about me and
if you ever need one of those things and
you see me you can
you know i'll help you out